adam duvall welcome back to atlanta jack
peterson moving to center field a
position that he's used to look at that
414 times he's played centerfield and
jorge soler hopefully he will electrify
that outfield and we'll get some
production and score a lot of runs the
mole dozer 6-7 250 coming right at
people so he goes to work and we are
underway with a fly ball hit to right
solaire on the run
he's in the middle of the warning track
and he leaps up and makes the catch so
there hadn't played much outfield
wouldn't you know what the baseball game
say here we go you get the first ball in
play
butler one two three inning nine pitches
that's impressive
here come the braves against brandon
woodruff the big woo brandon woodruff
yeah just outstanding numbers he leads a
national league in earned run average
second in all the baseball only to lance
lynn the 1-2 pitch and a swing and a
miss and there's strikeout number one
for the big woo
another strikeout for brandon woodruff
not messing around with alby straight
gas two up two down
on the
and the pick from escobar we've talked
about this team's work defensively and
another example right there
kane it's one on the ground and through
in a base hit
two aboard with one away here in the
second
and
that gets away as the runners will
advance i thought it might hit yeah it
did hit him there was no reaction but
now he did get hit in the foot so the
lease is on and the bases are loaded
the 1-2 on the ground to riley chance to
get two but the throw is wide alby's
able to hold the bag
a run will score
so here's the debut of jorge solaire
former cup former royal
broken bat muscled into shadow left
center and outreach of adamus and jorge
solaire debuts with a broken bad hit
smoked and in a right field
this guy keeps hitting he's got to keep
playing
for zola 2 when lance lynn got him on
two now and this time to the breaking
ball leaning over
great pitch right there by mueller to
get wong
aces adamus is down on strikes and
mueller has gone into more of an attack
mode here in this third inning
strike three just struck out the side
look at mueller
here comes a 1-2
chain jump right back to woody
side retired nice clean inning for
brandon woodruff
and that missed so the brewers have
runners at first and seconds the pitch
strike three at the letters mueller gets
out of it
riley at first with one out
and that smoke did a left center field
at base hit riley around second he's
chugging toward third he's gonna make it
without a throw
hit number 500 for solaire
who's two for two and hands be flat out
to right his first time up let's see
what he can do here with first and third
one out in the fourth inning
that's why game time exactly why
back to back hits for atlanta
dansby didn't wait that's rbi number 51.
long anchored at first the pitch
popped him up
right behind the plate
vogue throws the mask staggers the
benton makes the play and kyle mueller
is through five with a 1-1 game nice job
kid
[Applause]
well with the right field garcia looks
up
and bangs off the bricks going to third
is peterson turning third heading home
through the play
is in time not at home is jack peterson
how many times are we going to see that
in this series they almost got thrown
out at home play with nobody out last
night
woodruff delivers
and raleigh missed it
shallow left center
tyrone taylor puts it away and that is
some good work
[Music]
[Applause]
runners lead with two out
on the ground riley vacuums that up and
he makes the peg to first jesse chavez
works around the walk and the air and
preserves a tie home sixth coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
dansby may have been taking a step
toward the braves dugout and manny pena
is letting cb buckner have it
bad decision there by dansby
duvall's running pitches hammer toward
left center field deep kane back track
wall braves leading
instead of strike three it's a two-run
homer
and pena and cb buckner
are still talking about it
about that exit velocity 102 off the bat
back up the middle but right into the
shift ozzy's got it and the inning is
over
[Applause]
little chop over the mound tough play
funny spin ozzy beats it out put it in
play with two strikes
[Applause]
as freddie shoots one that way it's a
base hit
freeman's got his second hit
hotshot they don't want to play
long throw to first and escobar can't
hang on one run is in
what a play by adamus and escobar
first game at first base can't hang on
and now swanson
the seventh man
to hit in the inning
swing and a high fly ball down the left
field line can he keep it fair at the
pole it hits the pole and it's a grand
slam
what a great opportunity for richard
rodriguez to debut for atlanta
double play ball there's one there's two
welcome to atlanta mr rodriguez two
singles but two for the price of one not
a safe situation for will smith
and you might wonder why brian smith why
brian snicker is bringing smith in in a
game like this
he's pitched twice in 11 days
jackie bradley jr their final hope
and on the ground freddie's got it fair
ball he'll flip to smith close play got
him in that jabal game 8-1 braves win